eric hat jetzt ist es also kurz vor der
wahl zum cdu vorstand paul hat es gerade
gesagt da gibt es noch keinen klaren
favoriten sagen die zahlen das genauso
und wenn ja gibt es zumindest einen der
ganz klar abgeschlagen ist und kein
favorit ist nein im gegenteil also die
drei sind näher zusammen ist es jeder
fall war
sowohl im blick auf die befragten
insgesamt als auch jetzt auf die
befragten unionswähler ist also sowohl
märz als auch laschet und röttgen sind
nah beieinander
und es wird nicht die frage ist sein das
ist der kandidat er jetzt der cdu
insgesamt den großen tisch bringt
sondern entscheidend wird sein welcher
kandidat ist derjenige in dem sich die
partei anschließend geschlossen
versammelt jetzt haben wir gerade auch
von paul gehört dass es sehr jetzt auch
gespräche von ihren sparen schon gab man
zuschauen wie seine lage so wäre wenn
der kanzler werden wollen würde macht
das auch irgendetwas jetzt mit den
zahlen von armin laschet denn immerhin
ist er in seinem team und das zeigt
jetzt nicht gerade viel rückhalt
also geht's laschet viel gewinnt weil
sparen indem teams
kann ich nicht sagen was man sagen kann
ist das natürlich sparen
von den vier cdu-politiker märz nach
sparen der populärste ist also im
ranking ist es letztlich so söder und
danach kommt sofort sparen
insofern ist das auch schon gesagt
worden ist sparen durchaus eine option
als gegenspieler zu
[Musik]
müller also söder könnte moment den
besten laufen blick auf die
kanzlerkandidatur sparen könnte ihm
gefährlich werden weil er eben vor den
drei vorsitzenden kandidaten liegt
erklärt wenn wir uns anschauen in der
letzten woche hat vor allem das impf
desaster die entscheidende politische
rolle gespielt auch in der diskussion da
gab es zahlen glaube ich von endet in
dieser woche die mir ersparen
bei -8 gesehen haben sozusagen in den
umfragen was was wissen sie darüber wie
sehr diese impfdiskussionen den
gesundheitsminister am ende schaden
könnte und dann ja vielleicht auch so
schaden könnte dass eben diese kanzler
optionen nicht mehr gezogen werden kann
ich glaube dass es erst die nächsten
wochen zeigen solche entwicklungen dass
da was hängen bleibt
das dauert eine zeit bis ich das
verfestigt mitte märz ging es rasant
nach oben weil die letzten jahres weil
die bevölkerung vor war da ist eine
regierung die an bild wir sind unsicher
in dieser pandemie aber die arch einen
plan zu haben
ich glaube jetzt ist immer noch da das
einhergeht und sagt es wird wegen ist
etwas getan die leute verstehen auch das
vielleicht hier und dort und das googeln
kann
es ist nicht so dass man da jetzt schon
in den nächsten tagen sehen wird das
geht nach das geht nach unten ich glaube
das ist so eine längerfristige
entwicklung oder insofern ist sicherlich
die überlegung zu sagen man schiebt die
entscheidung über die kanzlerkandidatur
nicht unklug um einfach zu sehen
was kann da noch passieren an stimmung
aber was nehmen sie wahr was die
delegierten beschäftigen könnte in
diesen tagen war das ist ja das
entscheidende nicht die frage wie viel
prozent jemand an der parteibasis
bekommen sondern am ende wie die
delegierten abstimmen werden was wissen
sie da was kann man da sagen was da an
themen an stimmungen rolle spielt ich
glaube dass die delegierten sich schon
wünschen dass jemand da ist der liga als
cdu-vorsitzender agiert und ein bisschen
auch diese nestwärme er bringt aber das
glaube ich bringen alle drei kandidaten
also das ist nicht so dass jetzt ein
kandidat da ist man sagt also das gibt
den totalen abfall für die union wieder
geschaut hat dass er nachher die
delegierten hinter sich hat das ist
etwas was wir ja ich muss gut ich nicht
feststellen können was wir wissen ist
dass
friedrich merz vor allem fdp und afd
wähler ziehen kann und dass röttgen wenn
es offensichtlich jetzt für die grünen
eher gefährlicher ist bei loosdorf
stimmen ziehen könnte herbig hat nochmal
zu den drei herren die nachher
miteinander diskutieren wie sieht denn
der trend aus also sozusagen alle sind
relativ nah beieinander aber bei wem
geht der fei nach oben seit dem sommer
und bei wem geht eher nach unten also
nach oben geht da eindeutig bei röttgen
rücken war der außenseiter
und der hat diese außenseiterposition
eigentlich abgegeben
der favorit des anfangs armin laschet
ist nicht mehr derjenige wo man sagt das
ist ein durchlauf der wird's also rücken
ist der gewinner des letzten halben
jahres und lasse dass er der verlierer
wenn sie jetzt weiter schauen denn die
nächsten tage die nächste woche was
erleben sie was die menschen momentan am
meisten bewegt also nehmen wir an die
delegierten sitzen da an ihrem computer
und müssen darüber nachdenken welcher
kandidat für die cdu am ende das beste
ist aber auch wer am ende eine wahl
gewinnen kann ist dass welche fragen
sind das ist es das impfen die korona
regeln was erleben sie da welche themen
werden möglicherweise noch unterschätzt
als nicola pandemie ist das thema was
aktuell absolut das thema gesundheit ist
das thema was im moment alles bestimmt
was auch die die themen bestimmt
entscheidend glaube ich ist nicht die
frage für die leute wären cdu
parteivorsitzende sondern entscheidend
wird durch das hatten sie vorher auch
diskutiert ist der punkt b wird
kanzlerkandidat und insofern wird wenn
wir eine woche weiter sind und cdu
vorsitzende gewählt ist wird nur noch
die frage sein wer ist kanzlerkandidat
und das ist nachher letztlich für die
umfragen auch für die bundestagswahl am
26 september die allein entscheidende
frage deutlich wichtiger als die frage
des parteivorsitzenden